you're gonna help us start a war with
hope
[Music]
every one when I saw the first Sicario I
didn't necessarily say this is
definitely gonna do another one did you
when you made it would you like to vote
I didn't think so we didn't know
actually shot the ending of Sicario I
think was in the first couple of days
but I know the president's adding drug
cartels to the list of terrorist
organizations you want to see this thing
through I'm gonna have to get dirty and
then I read the script to be called in
and being like perhaps involved in a
sequel and then when I read the
cigarette this is a good movie on its
own if you change the characters this
movie sue Carter they of the Soldado
will still work so it's kind of like a
new chapter it's gonna get rid of her I
can't do that don't put me in that
situation you got to do what you got to
do I talked to fans about Sicario
they're here a fan favorite in that
movie they love how badass you are
so do you kind of up it in this filming
there's a couple moments you're gonna op
it but but but you know there's like
twisted turns I was surprised with
myself I think you learn more about how
he deals were like obstacles on how he
deals were like really adversity
[Music]